Hello everyone, good afternoon. Uh,
welcome to CNS 427, uh,
supercharging the testing with
Quiro. My name is Aarti.
I am based in Singapore and I work with
customers in Southeast Asia. I've got
Thomas.
Hi, I'm Thomas. I'm based,
based in Sydney. I look after startups
across OIPJ focusing on agentic coding.
Alright, I hope you've all had a good Reinvent
so far, um, almost the end of
Reinvent.
So in today's talk, we are gonna talk about
how you can use Agentech AI
across your surless development life cycle,
specifically to simplify testing.
Now testing is a vast topic. Uh,
so today we will focus on automated
functional tests for Servalli, which is unit
tests, integration tests, and end to
end tests.
So this is a Level 400 talk, so we assume
the audience is familiar with Servallis and also
some of the basics of coding.
So to first understand the challenges with Serveli,
let's start with what's a bit different about
Serveless applications.
Um, Serveless applications are highly distributed
or modular, uh, which means they have
a larger number of integrations as opposed
to traditional apps,
and they also make use of a lot of cloud native
services.
Now this has implications for the testing
process where it becomes important to test the
integration layers as well.
And one of the questions that comes up very often
for automated tests is handling dependencies
for isolated tests, that is, should you
mock them or should you emulate them, or
just use AWS services.
And finally,
your Lambda functions themselves may not be
complex enough, so how do you think about things
like coverage or where should you actually
focus your testing efforts?
So today we are going to see how Quiro can
help us with each of this pillar,
starting with how you should write your
applications to make it easy to test,
how you can use Agentic AI to generate the
tests, and finally how you can combine
the power of NCP servers with agents
to kind of use historic data to
continuously improve the quality of your
applications. So
because our
focus is testing in today's talk, we've actually
pre-built the application which is just a
task management API that uses
Amazon API gateway as a REST API,
Lambda for processing, and Dynamo DB for
the persistence layer.
There is also an asynchronous component where
any task events are published out to Amazon
Event Bridge, and then they are consumed by
a notification service.
So throughout the next hour or so, we are
going to evolve both the application and
write the test for this application, for
this task API.
Uh, so with that, we are good to start and
we're gonna switch to the IDE.
I It's
stopped mirroring, I think.
It's not mirroring.
It's not mirroring, sorry.
Sorry, just give us a second.
Um, so I'm gonna start off by taking
you through a quick code walkthrough of
the current application.
Now, we have chosen Python in this particular
case, but a lot of the best practices we talk
about will apply for any other
programming language as well.
Now as we go through the code base, this is a slightly
trimmed down version of the code.
So we have published the full version of this
application to GitHub and we'll be sharing the links with
you later on.
Uh, so for, for this talk, we just want you to
focus more on how the code is
structured and the actual flow
and how we're gonna evolve it.
Um, so real quick, if we
look at the directory structure currently,
um, we are just gonna focus on the
task API behind API gateway.
Uh, all of the code is in the task API folder
and our tests are in the test folder, and we'll
start with just the unit test for now.
So, just a quick check. Can everybody see the
code? Is it big enough?
If not, just raise your hand. We'll, OK,
cool. So let's start
with our lambda handler first. Uh,
so we are using power tools here to simplify
implementing some of the serverless best
practices.
The handler itself, we've gone down,
we've chosen to kind of combine all the task
CRD operations into a single lambda function
as against a micro lambda,
but Power tools makes it really easy to route
the request to the correct function. So for example,
if you get a post on the slash slash task
endpoint, it'll end up invoking our
create task function.
Uh, so it's fairly straightforward, we first parse
the event to extract what we want, which
is just our task details.
We build the task object.
Then we process the task to our database, in
this case Dynamo DB.
We publish the event and then we construct
the response and there is some basic error handling
here. Um, our task handler
also enforces some of the business
rules. So as an example, if you're updating
a task and you're defining dependencies
between the tasks, you don't want to end up with circular
dependency.
So in, in this case, when you update a task, there
is a check here where we are, we've created
a helper function that validates dependencies,
but the rest of the flow is the same. You update
the database, you publish the event, and then you
construct your response.
Um, our helper function here,
given a task, it basically queries the
database to build the existing dependency
graph, and then it's going to
just pass through the graph to identify if you're
going to violate the rule or not.
Model's file is pretty straightforward. This has
just our data classes.
Our domain logic has business rules. Again,
in the real world scenario, you would have a lot more rules
here, but to keep things simple, we will simply
focus on the circular dependency check for
the demo today.
So the idea here is given a task, it's
dependency and the dependency graph from the
database, this is just doing a depth-first
search to identify circular dependency.
And then the very last file we have here is
the integrations where we define the integration
with AWS services.
So you can see we've used Boto 3 initialized
our clients here.
And this is the class that, this is the module
that has the implementation of the methods invoked
from our handler.
So our safe task to Dynamo DB ends up calling
the put item
API and likewise, uh, this is
where we actually publish the event to event
bridge. Um,
let's take a very quick look at how we've
written the unit test for our Task Handler.
Now, because our task actually
persists tasks to Dynamo DB and publishes
events, if we have to unit test this, we
have to mock out those dependencies.
So in this particular case, currently we are using
Moto. So Moto is a Python library
specifically designed to kind of mock out
BTO 3.
So that makes our life a little bit easier in
a couple of ways.
So our P test fixtures are just the reusable
setup and tear down for our tests.
As a best practice, we have set set the AWS
credentials to dummy values for our unit tests.
So with Moto 3 you just need to use the
mock AWS context Manager,
and the advantage is because it's designed for
Boto 3, you're still using the same Boto
3 client calls.
What this is also doing transparently
is that it's monkey patching the Boto 3
calls during runtime. Basically it'll
intercept calls to Boto 3 at runtime
and replace it with our mock.
Uh, we also need to mock our event bridge. We
have created a mock test context, and
just a quick look at two tests. Our
first test is a
successful scenario where,
given a task, we create the task
successfully within the database.
So we need to pass our our fixtures
as arguments to the test case.
We import the handler,
we create our test event.
We invoke the lambda handler with the event
and the context, and that's that we validate
the response, you can optionally test the mock
state as well.
And then let's take a look at another test case
uh that enforces the circular dependency
rule. This test is a little
bit more involved than the first because
this depends on the dependency graph
existing in the database. So as part of
setting up this test,
we need to create a few tasks, in this case
task one and task 2,
and we persist these tasks to our mock
Dynamo DB database.
And the rest of the steps are pretty much the same.
We create the test event, invoke the handler,
only in this case we expect an error
response. So I'm gonna run this
test in a second to show what happens.
Uh, but this is our current code base. So kind
of the question here is, you know, let's say our
Business rules change in the future,
the needs change, and maybe we need to
replace Dynamo DB with something else,
maybe DocumentDB or maybe we need to replace EventBridge with
something else.
So can you think about the implications of
this? So, of course, we'll have to update our integrations
file to talk to the new services,
but just from a testing or developer experience
perspective, do you see any challenges with the way
the code is written right now?
You can just shout out the answers
and I'll just run the test suite. How many of you
ran into difficulties when you were trying to change
the integration architecture and
then you had to change all the testing,
all the related code afterwards, just give us a raise of
hands.
There you go.
Yeah, so, so just as we did the code
walkthrough like you,
so our test cases, for
example, that's testing the handler code,
and it's, you know, just basically testing
the response status
and the details of the response returned,
that test will have to be updated because now
the mock will have to be changed to work with the
new services we pick.
Um, so this kind of creates, so although you
did not change the actual code that was
tested by the test case, you need to rewrite
all those tests. So this kind of,
you know, creates extra work.
So I have just run the test here. Um,
so for those not familiar with Python,
so poetry, it's just a library commonly used
for packaging and dependency management,
and PyTest is a really common testing framework
in Python.
So I've turned on the timing for our tests
here. Um, so you can see that there is a
slight overhead in our setup where we are initializing
the mock functions and it varies
between 400 to 500 milliseconds.
Um, so in this case, we've only got 2
tests, um,
the actual runtime depends on whether the dependencies
are cached or not, so we've run this a few times
in our laptop,
but there's kind of, you know, room to
probably improve and make our tests a little bit faster.
So just given this code base,
Let's quickly summarize what we have seen.
Um, currently, the way we've written the
code, this is very tightly coupled to the infrastructure
choices. So if you have to change anything
on the AWS layer, you end up rewriting
test, uh, that would, that should not really
be affected by the change.
There is a little bit of friction with the developer
experience that you do need to know for mocking
exactly how the services work.
And then of course there, there's room to potentially
improve our tests and make them faster.
So now I'm gonna pass it over to Thomas to see
how we should address these problems and what's
the best way to write the tests.
Thanks, Arie. Before we proceed, how many
of you are Python developers?
Just give us a raise of hands.
Good number. For those of you that, that don't work with
Python, don't worry, all these principles
are applicable across the board for. We just picked
Python just because we are familiar with it,
but all the principles essentially can.
Uh, be applied to anything and everything.
Uh, just give me one second.
Oops.
All right.
So. Arie walked us
through our current architecture, uh,
we saw some pitfalls in there. Uh, now
let's
have a look at how we're going to fix it.
So what I'm going to do, I'm going to use
Kro CLL for this particular task.
Now just give me one second, I'll just fire
it up.
And You may notice
that I'm not using the traditional
uh invoke command for Kira CLI. I'm
using something that's called custom agent,
and I'll tell you what a custom agent is
just in just a minute.
I'm just going to pass a prompt which
essentially is asking Kira to
do a review of my current architecture
and propose, uh,
or suggest what are the problems and also
propose how to fix them.
So I'll just execute that and we'll get
to that
in a minute. I'll just leave it running.
I just want to show you.
What's under the hood. So if we go to a Kiro
folder in our project folder,
we'll have a section called agents.
If I opened it up and I'll.
Just remove this for a minute.
And make this a little bit bigger.
So this is essentially a configuration of a custom
agent. Now, what a custom agent is,
it's an instance of Kiro agent
or Kiro CLR agent rather, that we can
configure for a specific task. So you can notice
that I have
a specific set of MCP servers
just for this particular operation, so,
and I'm also passing a description and a
prompt
to uh the agent which is
used alongside of my prompt that I passed
to it. So this is think of it
as a specialized agent for a particular task.
So in our case it's going to be evaluating our architecture.
You can have a specialized
security auditing,
uh, agents. You can have compliance agents, etc.
agents, etc.
So it depends on your use case, uh, that
you would use. Uh, we also have a built-in
agents that we released this week, agreement,
uh, such as the, uh, AWS Security
and AWS AWS DevOps agents
which are
on the side of Quiro. They're not
inside of Quiro at the moment, but.
Uh, these are capabilities that you can configure inside of
the Kira or Kiro CLI brow.
We also configure tools, uh, so
it's, it's quite customizable. You can configure steering
files that actually tweak how
the agent operates and what kind of output it
returns. So, with that said, let's
go back to our terminal.
And let's double check what the response is essentially.
So we can see that Kiro on the scroll
all the way up.
Kiiro did a review and it
did use.
Uh, did read our whole project
essentially, uh, at points here
and there it used the MCP configuration just
to enhance its answers and generated
a full hexagonal, hexagonal architecture
audit report,
uh, that we can either read in this
terminal format or we can read it in a
proper MD format,
uh, which I'll show you and it's probably
easier to
read. I'll just flip here.
So there's a few sections
there. I'm not gonna go through that in detail, but this
just showcases how you can leverage agentic
AI to help you with
current review and kind of also
look around corners because you know we are
developers we know what we're doing, but
sometimes we don't account for every single scenario.
and we may not see everything that's related
to our application that might be potentially needing
updated updates or or being,
uh, need to be improved
so we can see already
that it it asks us or it
suggests us to fix, um, the domain logic
dependencies.
Uh, there's going to be more, uh,
section essentially related to the pattern how
we design the architecture of the
application, etc.
Uh, as I said, I'm not gonna go through this in a
whole heap of detail,
but, uh, you can see there's quite a
bit of
information there. Now, why is this useful?
Because we can essentially
go to Quiro and we can ask,
ask it to.
You can notice I mean a spec
kind of uh spec uh flow
which creates
spec driven development essentially
uh spec specs that we can use
to quantify the requirements, design and
implementation of individual tasks. It's
particularly useful for for feature
or general software development,
but in our case we're going to use it
to create a plan
to integrate the changes that Kiiro
actually suggested us to do.
So I'll just reference the file.
That has our.
Evaluation our audit
and I'll ask you to generate.
It's just while Thomas is doing this, so,
uh, I think he mentioned hexagonal architecture.
So the thinking there was because our code base
was kind of tightly coupled with the different
concerns, so the idea was how do
we decouple it, and hexagonal architecture
is one way to do that. So the idea
is you have got code
or ports that only deal with the interfaces,
and you've got the core business logic, and then
you have a glue layer that connects the interface
to the business logic.
So we have kind of used that as a baseline
to uh rearchitect the code.
Exactly. So
we can see that this was a little bit faster than usual
just because I actually have a spec spec
created just for the sake of time,
but normally Kira would go in and
create the whole spec from the ground up with
requirements, design, and tasks, we can see
those three files in here,
referenced and actually gives us a description
of what it
did. Now, I'll show you how those
files actually look like.
So if I go back to my Kiro folder,
I'll just minimize this.
We have a folder called specs, and
in there we have a
hexagonal spec.
If I open the requirements, I'll
just get.
This here and,
Oops, sorry.
Where am I?
Here, OK,
so, um, in the requirements
file, oops see Daisy, hold on.
There's always something with live demo.
OK, let's minimize this. There we go.
So this is our requirements file. You can see that we
have
introduction, we have glossary to kind of
understand all the terms, and we have all the requirements and
especially acceptance criteria that are needed
for every single project,
any single change that you're running to your
project, be it a feature, be it architecture,
be it anything essentially, it's very, very useful
when working with AI especially.
Now the next file that he created for
us is design. So this is the full
design of changes we can actually see
the diagram of changes that it'll be implementing
into into
the process. This is the target architecture, how
it's going to
augmented or rather decouple, uh, uh,
features to make them more flexible, more versatile,
and, uh, easier to test as well.
Uh, I'm not gonna go through all of this
in detail. I just want to highlight the process.
But the most important thing here is the task
list. Now
here we could go to Quiro and ask it to
essentially
start executing these either in,
in sequence 11 by one,
do the whole project ess essentially in one
go. Depends how much time you have.
Depends if you're doing something on the side, but you can essentially
delegate this to Kiro to
go through on its own.
Observe it at some point,
um, verify that it's doing the job that it's
supposed to do,
uh, but essentially
do the migration or rather refactoring
of the obligation on the go on its own.
So, um,
I'm gonna make it easy on myself, I'll just fast forward.
Normally this would take a little bit of time, let me
just. Make this a little
bit bigger. I hope you can see everything now.
Uh, OK.
So, just to illustrate
the original state that we had when
Arti was going through the application,
we had something like this.
We had everything kind of coupled together. Yes, we had
some files that were separate, but
it was all kind of bundled together
with tightly coupled references.
So all the HTP passing, business logic
and, and all the integration calls
were kind of stuck together.
Now, after the audit
and the implementation of that, uh, of those
findings of the audit,
uh, we would use Quiro
through Spector and approach
to
modify our architecture, refactor it.
This is how it would look like. This is the current state
of our architecture.
So we can see we still have our handler, but
it's much, much leaner.
Uh, it's only processing HTTP requests. Then
we have all the business logic kind of offloaded
to our domain layer, and I'll go through this
in more detail in a second.
Uh, and then also through interfaces,
uh, we are communicating with the, uh, adapters
that are,
uh, invoking our services, so the integration.
Now how does this actually look like?
If I go to the task handler again, and
I'll just minimize this side.
So,
in our main handler, uh, we
have a method called create task, right?
So The important
bit here is that
we're no longer coupling anything, we're calling
a delegated task service.
Now if I scroll up here.
And I go to the site,
essentially,
so. That action
is calling the domain logic.
If I flip to domain logic,
essentially, and I'll go to
the top of the task service.
We can see that this particular service
requires a repository
and even publisher to be to process.
So there's two kinds of streams that we, we see.
Uh, we have.
One way that one stream that essentially
uh does an operation when we
don't specify them, and I'll show you what that does,
but if we if we do specify them we
can point it to specific
integration that we can manage.
Now what does this mean?
So if we would, uh,
essentially not specify these these uh parameters,
our application would default to
what it has under the hood and we'll use
interfaces.
To use what we call protocols now
protocols are specifically for Python, but what they
essentially do,
they create contracts without the need
to, uh, set implementation,
and this is what you can see here because the, the
methods in our class for Tel repository
protocol are pretty much empty. There's nothing
really in there
now. Why this is
good, because we can point it to
anything, right? But in our case,
If we go back to the logic, essentially we can see
that the
repository in this case is set to
none. Which
means that we are calling integrations.
And through integrations.
If I go to integrations we are calling our integration
to general MoDB or the even bridge,
right? And we can manage this we can modify
this we can point it to something else if
we need to,
uh, this is for the case where we did not
specify the repository and the
even publisher.
If we do specify it, it depends on
what we specify.
The route will be different essentially, and this is
particularly useful
for tests,
um, so back to
our architecture, just wanna recap here.
This is how the decoupling would work here.
And in terms of what we covered essentially
in this part of the the session,
uh, we essentially uh showed
how the handle performs the the validation.
um I'll just take this off.
Uh, we, we saw how the domain logic
is essentially containing all the business
logic and business functionality.
We saw how the integration
layer works.
And then, uh, also
we saw how the abstraction works with the handler
its own, so we are obstructing the logic, the
business logic and the integration from the handle itself,
and we are relying on the domain
to kind of interface to the repository or the
publisher to create a contract
and, um,
afterwards the integration implements,
uh, through the interface straight away services.
And back to you. Yeah, I, I'll show
you the test. So just to recap,
the task,
our domain logic just expects
a task repository that offers the
safe task method
or a delete task method. It does not
know whether it is implemented using Dynamo
DB or Aurora or whatever might
be the service,
and the exact implementation logic is
contained within our integration layer.
So if you go back to the problem suite statement of
swapping, say, Dynamo DB with something else,
your integration.
changes,
but as long as the database is exposed
through the same safe task method,
we don't need to change the tests in our handler
and the logic code.
So I'm going to now actually code out
the tests and then we'll see how
that looks different or simpler than
before. Now,
we'll start with the task handler, uh
sorry, the test for the task Handler.
Before I move to the test, there's one thing I wanted to
call out. So if you saw when Thomas
walked us through the code, we did not
directly initialize the task service
and the handler.
We actually used the get task
service method. Um,
so what we are doing here is setting up our
code for dependency injection. I'm gonna
talk a bit about why that makes testing
easier. Again, those of you familiar with
Java, this will probably seem intuitive,
not so much in the Python world, but we'll see how we
can do it.
So if we actually look at the Get task service,
um, it looks for a service level
uh variable taskservice.
If this is set, it's gonna return it as
it is, but if it's not, it's going to initialize
the task service, and this is the flow
that would actually kick off when our lambda is
actually invoked in production. So,
The key thing I want to call is
at runtime our application does not
rely on dependency injection
because we have provided default ways for the
flows.
So this piece of additional code was specifically
written to simplify testing, and we'll
see how that simplifies testing.
So let's go back to our
test task handler.
At this point, our handler still relies on
the domain logic or the task service,
so we still need to mop that out to test this
in isolation from the rest of the code base.
So the way to do that would be.
Let's say we start off by mocking,
get tasked.
All right, something like this. I'll, I'll
accept this and I'll explain like what this is doing.
So now to unit test our task handler,
we need to mock out only the domain logic,
so we are no longer concerned with the actual AWS
services in use.
We just want to validate that our task handler
works well and returns the correct response
code to our end client.
So we need to do a couple of things.
One is we are going to mock the Getar service
to return a mock object.
Um, so in this case,
that service is called the MC task, MC
Gta Service.
If you remember when we spoke about motto for
Boto 3, motto is automatically
understands BTO 3 API calls, but in this
case, this is a custom mock, so we
need to configure the behavior of the mock task
service. So within our test case,
we will have to go ahead
and say configure mock.
So we, I'm gonna just keep
this simple, but basically you will have to specify
the return value. I won't accept this because
we're gonna do the test a bit differently, but
just to give you the picture, first, I need to
create what the return value for a successful
create task call looks like.
And then we also need the monkey patching
because the patch now has to be managed
by our tests. So essentially every time get task
Services call, we want to insert our mock
into the picture.
That's basically what this test is doing.
Now the thing with this approach is,
remember we just wrote two sample tests, but
we are gonna write tests for all our different
resources and methods,
and at times we want to simulate the error.
So depending upon the behavior we want to simulate,
our mock will either have a return value
or a side effect, which would simply be raising
the exception.
So what happens, it's all our test code
is now riddled with a whole bunch of mock
code,
and we also need to patch the code at runtime.
Now the tricky thing with patching at runtime
is it it can get brittle because if
we change the logic of the domain service, it
can break in unexpected ways,
and also patching can sometimes leak
states across tests,
and this is where we are going to use dependency injection.
So I'm not,
instead we are not going to use the mock service, so
let's see how
dependency injection simplifies our life.
So the first thing is we want a highly configurable
mock whose return value can be changed
depending on the test we are running, whether it's
an error or a success scenario.
So what we really need is a configurable
fake task service. Um, so
this is just an in-memory fake at this point,
this is not a mock.
So what we have done is you can initialize the
fake task service with a bunch of flags
that tells whether the service raises an exception
or just works as expected and follows
the happy path.
So for example, it has the same methods that
our task service offers,
but when we call create tasks, the first check
we do in this in memory fake is to check
whether the exception flag is set.
If set, it'll raise an exception, if not,
it'll go ahead and simply return the task
object. So in scenarios
where you want to highly customize
the behavior of
of your dependency,
it is kind of easier to do that with
in memory fakes rather than a mock.
So the complexity of the mock configuration
has now moved here, so we are not
essentially writing additional code, but it's just
where the complexity goes. It's now in the in-memory
fake.
Now this is the first step. Now we of course
need a fixture again,
uh, because the second step is we, we
need to replace the original
task service call with this mock. So how are we
going to do that?
We said patching is brittle, so what we
are going to do instead
is we are going to use dependency injection
here. So within our pi test fixture
now, we initialize the fake task service.
Now if you remember, our get task service
looks for the module level variable, whether it's
set or not.
So in our test, we are basically setting
that module level variable to our fake task
service, and we have basically injected
our in-memory fake into the test.
Um, and that's it, so anything before the yield is
set up and after the yield statement is your tear
down in Python.
And contest is a file that PyTest
automatically loads, it's just where your reusable
code goes.
So how does this actually make our test
cleaner? So the first thing is
we, we want to use our fake,
all right,
we will probably go to,
we don't need this, this was generated.
So I'll stick to the previous um
structure we had for the test and let's see what
changes.
The first thing is we are now going to make
use of the fake tasker,
so we need to pass this as a variable.
We still create our test event. Now
remember, the behavior of our fake task
service when the flag is not set
is to just return a successful task
response.
So all we need to do to run our tests here.
is we import our handler code.
So this should actually look
similar to what we were doing.
In the old tests.
I then invoke this.
All right, the autocomplete is a bit
laggy.
But basically, we're going to do the same thing that we did
before. I called the lambda handler directly
with the event and the mock lambda context.
And then all we need to do here,
it's all right, it generated this time.
Uh, we can optionally validate the response, but
I'll keep it simple for the demo.
So if you look at it, that's about it for
testing the happy path for the test task
handler. We have used the fake task service,
which gets injected into our task
domain and it is simulating all the different
scenarios that our task service can
raise. So as an example, now if we
take the case for the circular dependency
error. If you remember
the previous code, we had all this logic
to basically create the dependency
map in the database and all of that.
That goes away because now I can simulate
an error simply by
Configuring the should raise circular
dependency flag
here. The rest of the steps are gonna
look similar to what we did
uh with the previous test.
So you can see here that our tests are now
vastly simplified. So what this means
as a developer in the future if our
domain logic changes or you change the
behavior of the task service, so this file is
the only place where I need to make changes
to get my unit test to work.
So having said that, it doesn't mean that
you should avoid mock at all costs. So for
example, if we take our notification service
that's processing things from the
Event Bridge,
let's say it is sending out an email when your task
is due as a reminder.
There, there's no need for me to fake
an entire email server or an SES
because that's a third party dependency. All
I need to know for that test is that
the send message method
was actually invoked and I'm good.
But for this particular case where we
own the code for the domain logic and we want
to highly customize the behavior
in memory fake combined with dependency injection
makes our code a lot cleaner.
But then that leads to the question, what about our domain
logic that actually validates that the circular
dependency function works?
So this becomes a whole lot simpler now
because this is just a pure function that
given a task and a dependency map, it
is just going to check and return true
if there is a circular dependency or false
if not.
So if we look at the test case for this, let's say.
Uh, this is our current dependency, except
I,
task one depends on task 2, let's say,
and task two has no dependency
at the moment.
I'm going to try to force a circular
dependency by calling this has circular
dependency,
and I passed this mock dependency graph I've
created, and all I need
to know is that this is going to return true.
The negative scenario is equally simple,
um, so I now have an empty
graph here.
And at this time this should basically
say that there is no circular dependency.
So that's it,
and these tests again, don't need to change.
In the future,
I mean, if you change the logic for how you
calculate circular dependency, all you need to
do is rerun the test.
So the effort kind of goes down.
And the third thing we called out was, um,
what is the impact of this on
the timing of the tests, so.
Um, so both of these are in
the unit folder, so we'll stick
to this.
So for, uh, so mock basically
Moto 3 is a uh library
that mocks all of the AWS services, so
it has a slightly bigger overhead.
But for our particular case, the in-memory
fake, as you can see, is barely 120
milliseconds, it's a lot more lightweight,
and our tests are that much more cleaner.
So we, we have now wrapped up our unit tests,
but kind of this takes us to the next
question. Um,
when you're using agentic AI or spec driven
development to build applications, uh, let's
say you use the requirements, build the code,
then you ask the agent to write the test
for the generated code,
um, and it might do a great job of comprehensive
tests.
But there is no way to validate that your
requirements were correctly translated
to the code in the first place. You know,
your tests are validating the code that's generated.
So how do you solve this problem, and Quiro
recently introduced property-based tests
to do that.
So while Thomas explains that, I'm gonna run
the test, but I'll explain what I'm doing after
he's done to save time, yeah.
Who has heard about the property-based testing
in Quiro or in general?
OK,
uh, I'll use an analogy to kinda
explain this. So think about a case where you're building
your new tests. It's kind of like building a bridge,
right? You build a bridge, you wanna test it, that
it actually holds the, the load that it's supposed
to be holding.
Now,
would you rather test it with your own
car only,
or would you rather test it with your car, my
car, Arti's car, a truck, an
ambulance?
An elephant,
right? So that's the difference between
the traditional way of creating
tests and the property-based testing.
With property-based testing, you essentially define properties.
And then the system
runs not just one test.
It can execute
100 tests
during the same execution, and Arthur is going to show
you how that actually looks like,
uh, using some menu modules,
but it's, it simplifies the
process because it makes it simple to define
but also faster to execute.
Yep, so,
like, like Thomas said, it's great to kind
of also detect edge cases in your
business logic. So the idea here is
we'll just see, I've, I've run this test and
I'll, uh, explain this in a minute.
I'll start with the scenario I'm trying to
explain. So if you think about a circular
dependency check, that's a good example where
property-based tests actually works well
because we just want to verify the algorithmic
correctness of that code and whether
it does what it is supposed to do. That's
really it.
So to do that, we are going
to kind of take a slightly
Um, all right, I.
Where is the code? I think I
might have the wrong file open. Hang on, just give me
a second.
OK, it's just doubled. Why
does it split it like that? Yeah, I think
I did that before.
All right, that's strange, so, OK, bear
with me. Yes,
so actually this is the first time Thomas and I are running
this together, so I'm not used to his laptop, so
please bear with me. So, all right, so
in this case, let's say this is the scenario we
want to test, OK, for algorithmic
correctness.
So, when you saw the unit test we
wrote for the domain logic, we created these simple
dependency graphs and we tested it, you know, like
we said, task one depends on task 2,
get task 2 to depend on task one, and it,
it should detect.
But let's say that there are complex kind of
dependencies that exist in our database
where, uh, you know, each of these nodes represents
a task essentially.
So let's say this task depends on 1, this
depends on 2, and so on.
Now, if I try to force this dependency
of this main 2 back to main zero,
now if there was a bug in the logic and let's say it
only travels the right side of this branch,
it might incorrectly conclude that, you know
what, this doesn't set up a circular dependency,
let's allow this to go through.
But if my logic is written correctly,
then it should test all branches
that it encounters on the way.
So this is a good use case where property-based
tests might help us.
So I've basically actually run the test.
So, a few quick
things to note.
So Python has a library called Hypothesis
that allows you to do property-based tests.
So obviously with property-based tests, instead of fixed
inputs, we are generating a large
number of inputs from a given problem
or input space.
However, the data is not completely random.
So in our case, task IDs are UU IDs,
so that's why I've used the strategies
here. In this case, to specify
that I want to create a bunch of UU IDs
for my testing because that's what I'm using for my
task.
Next, let's just focus on this branching test.
Um,
you see the given decorator here defines
the input space to be used to generate
the test.
So I'm just gonna refer to them as main chain
and branch chain as I showed you in the diagram.
I'm just generating a list of task
IDs. I've specified a few constraints
as to how many,
and the ID should be unique, because, of course, each
task is unique within our database.
Similarly for the branch chain, and then I'm also
specifying that we randomly choose a
point on the main chain where we want to create the
branch.
Now if you look at the test case.
We also define a few additional constraints.
For example, we don't want any overlap
between the two lists,
because we are using UU IDs there's a good chance,
we won't actually breach this constraint.
And the test itself is pretty simple. Basically
I'm looping over the list of task
IDs generated for the main chain and I'm
building this left side of the branch
first, and then I do the same
for the second set of the list and building this
right side of the branch first.
Then I actually pick the point where I want to
define the branch, so if there are any
existing dependencies there, I want to preserve the
dependency, and that, that's really it. I've built
at this point,
the dependency map, uh, in the database,
and that's it. I just.
You know, loop back the last node back to
the first node, and then I expect that it'll
detect the dependency every time. So the way
we have written the test has changed.
Second, I ran this test already
and. You can see
that for each of the tests there is about
0.34, 0.32. There is a
little bit of an overhead in running the test, although
these are still unit tests.
So what exactly is happening behind the scene?
So to understand that I've installed this
open source plug-in called
Tikiy. Sorry, I'm just gonna
have to run this again because.
All right, got it this time around.
So this, this plug-in makes it easy
to visualize what's happening under
the hoods with property-based tests,
specifically. So what this is showing us
is, I, I specifically chose just the
test that we did.
Uh, the important thing to note is it did not
run a single test for this function. It
ran 100 test cases, each
with a unique combination of inputs.
But you'll also see here that the generated number
of samples is 104.
That's because it created 104 sets
of inputs, but 4 of them were discarded
because it did not meet some of our constraints, and,
and that's OK.
Our test itself, actually each test
runs pretty fast, but it's just
that it's running 100 of them, so that's
what it's adding to the overhead.
Now this visualization in, in our case, the
good news is we wrote the logic correctly
and you can see all 100 of them passed and that's
good. But when you have failures
as a developer, it's good to look at what
was the input for which the thing failed,
so it's easy to troubleshoot,
and that's where this helps again because if you click
into this you can actually see every
single input. In this case, of course, everything was
successful,
but you can see what was the main chain, what is
the branch chain, what is the branch point.
It even tells you the actual code coverage,
what were the lines that were tested by this,
and it makes it easy for you to troubleshoot
things. So that kind of wrap wraps
this up. So kind of where this is useful is
anywhere algorithmic correctness or, you know, pure
functions, business logic,
really good, especially to catch edge cases.
But the moment you're thinking about say end to end
tests or so on, they're not so good because
for end to end tests you need specific inputs
that will
actually trigger your end to end workflow and
random data might not really help you there.
But that's a good way or even if you don't
run it as part of every CI, it's a good way
to validate correctness of core
kind of business critical business logic and whether
that works as expected.
All right, so that wraps up this one.
So we're actually good to move
on to the integration
test. So we've finished our unit test.
So for the integration test, the first one I wanna
uh discuss is just uh validating
the schema for asynchronous integration,
which is our event bridge part.
Uh, so what exactly does schema test do?
So the goal here is as a publisher of an
event,
if I modify my event such that
I maybe remove fields that my subscribers
depend on, I'm gonna break the logic of my downstream
subscribers.
So that's really what the schema test is for. So
if you have any breaking changes in your event schema,
it's going to pick this up.
Now our task API is super simple and I
think it's fair to assume that it's the same team
that owns both the code bases and maybe you can
coordinate the changes.
But the moment you have like a central event bus,
multiple publishers, multiple subscribers,
where publishers often don't even know who the subscribers
are, it becomes more and more important
to validate uh the contract of the test.
So again, there are a few different ways to write this.
It depends on how you're defining your event schema.
For example, Async API is one way to define
your schema or Open API,
then you can use tools specific to those.
But because we are in Python, we're gonna do it the Pythonic
way, and we're using Pedantic, which is just
a data validation library.
So defining a schema is as simple as inheriting
from the base model,
and I've basically defined what a task,
create event or update event will look like.
If the task is deleted, of course the schema will
just have the ID.
There's another important thing we are checking because we're
using EventBridge, and EventBridge expects
a few mandatory fields, otherwise you can't
publish to it. So we are also validating the
compliance to EventBridge schema.
Now actually running the test is easy. I've, I've
got a helper function here, so validating a
schema is as simple as just calling
the model validate
on the class with the event, and that's it.
So my actual test cases are generating
the create event, delete event, and so on, and
just calling this helper method, and, and we're
good to go.
There are a few advanced other ways to test this,
for example, consumer-driven contract tests
and so on. So but if you're interested, just find
us after this, after this talk, and we can
talk about it.
Now, let's come to just integration with actual
AWS services, um, which
is Dynamo Devi and EventBridge. So our
recommendation here is for AWS
services,
test against the actual services.
Uh, that way you also get to validate
the other integration properties such as, you know,
whether permissions are set up correctly or
networking is set up correctly, and so on.
Uh, the other thing to think about also is with mocking
libraries is whether the libraries fully
support those services. So as an example, Moto
that we, you know, used, uh, in the initial
version does not support global tables
for Dynamo DB out of the box.
Then you will have to manage that replication
within your code.
So that's another thing to think about if you are
relying on MOOCs.
Um, so let's quickly take a look at Dynamo DB.
Like we said, we are going to test this against the
real, uh, database.
So our test fixture is straightforward. So if you
remember the integration code that
uh Thomas walked you through, you initialize the task
repository with the actual table name.
We are going to modify the
UU ID because we don't want to leave the test data
around so that we can delete this. So
we are gonna fix what is the ID
of the task.
Uh, there's the cleanup that basically deletes the task.
Now there are two types of tests here. One is
the happy path scenario, you create,
you know, and you make sure that the tasks are persistent.
I create the task object.
I kind of use my
P test fixture task ID for it.
I simply call save task, if you remember the
protocol that he mentioned, save task allows
you to persist the task to the database,
and that's it. Then we retrieve the task from the database
and we're good to go.
So again, remember in the future, if you swap Dynamo
DV with something else, this test case actually does
not change at all.
You simply rewrite your integration code and run
this as is, and, and it should
work. Oh well, you
will have to rewrite the code to retrieve the
data based on the database you're using,
but a large part of the test remains unchanged.
Now, the more interesting part of this test is
actually the failure scenarios.
So the first thing to call out here is, again, we are simulating
errors with services. Once again,
in memory fake comes to our rescue, so we
have a fake class. I won't go through it, it's similar
to what we did with the unit test.
But the question here is, what exactly is it we
should be validating with failures?
So there are two things we should be uh checking
for. First is,
are we surfacing the correct error
code or exception code and message so
that the client knows what to do with it,
or are we just collapsing everything into a 500
and then troubleshooting becomes hard?
The second thing to test is does your
application behave as expected when these
error scenarios occur.
So to make it concrete, let's again go back to our
application, like, uh, let's say for our task app,
we have an
offline mode, so people can
work on tasks offline.
And probably when they come online, it's possible that
you might end up with conflicts in tasks.
So how are you going to resolve the conflict? So we have used
a simple strategy of first right wins.
So we have a version which is the Unix timestamp
of a record, so when a client reads it and
then they write back, if the timestamp is changed,
you know, the right will be rejected.
But the error message should convey enough,
so the client knows what to do with it.
So the way we're going to do this is um
In this case, we should return a 409 conflict
error. Um, so what we will do is,
now this is going to start to look similar
to the unit test.
So the question is, first, is this an integration
test because we're, we're just using uh MCs.
The second question is, are we repeating what we did with
the handler test?
So for the first question, in this case, we are
evaluating a failure with
the integration layer for Dynamo DB so it
logically kind of sits as part
of the Dynamo DB test validation.
So we have left it in here with the integration
test. The second thing is it's not
an exact repetition of
the handler test, um,
because if you remember in the handler, we mocked out the
entire task service logic layer, we injected
our fake there. So that part of the
code was never tested.
But if you look at the fake that we have created
here, So
the first thing we are doing is we are creating the task
repository, but we are using a fake. So
once again,
dependency injection, we injected the fake
database into task repository.
We are using a mock for the publisher. So
here again, mock is handy for us
because when I'm testing database failures,
I don't want to publish any events to EventBridge,
that's all.
I don't need to actually configure
the behavior of EventBridge, so here mock is
super handy for me just to prevent
events from being published to EventBridge.
And then I actually instantiate the task
service with the fake repo and fake publisher,
so we are testing all of the code
that has been written in the task service, so it's not a
repetition.
You could choose directly to validate the
task service and not call the handler.
The reason we chose the handler is that we are also
mapping some of the error codes.
That is, for example, when you have an IAM
error, which is a permission error,
and Lambda doesn't have permission to write to Dynamo DB,
this permission error has no meaning to your end
client. So here we actually
check that your error message does not
have, um,
oh, I'm looking at the wrong test case.
Right, that's the test case, sorry. So here we
actually check that your error message does
not have permission or access in the message
and you're basically surfacing IAM errors
as internal error.
So that's why we chose to test the handler.
And then the last one.
Uh, for EventBridge,
the main difference with the EventBridge test is unlike
Dynamo DB, you can't really query EventBridge
because you publish an event and it's gone,
unless there is a subscriber.
So testing EventBridge requires a little bit of extra
work where we are setting up a test harness,
which is just another lambda function that's
listening to test events.
It adds a bunch of metadata and persists
it to another Dynamo DB and then we just
read back from the Dynamo DB.
So if we look at the Happy Path case for
this, we initialize the publisher
with the real event buzz,
we create the event and we just call published task
event. Because
there is extra work in kind of lambda receiving
the event, processing and persisting it, we do
introduce a wait time here.
Uh, to allow for that, and then we basically query
the target database and we are, we are
done. So I'm
going to just run these tests, which actually
take a little bit time to run,
uh, but
we'll have this running and I'll pass it off
to
Thomas
to finish the last part.
Um,
so, OK, while that runs,
very quickly summarizing,
what we did for the test was MCs
are useful, but use them sparingly, and
we saw at least 2 or 3 places where we did use
the mock.
However, when you want to customize the behavior of
your domain logic, uh, in memory fakes
work better.
Dependency injection makes the code cleaner,
but remember at runtime we have provided
defaults, so the code at runtime does
not require dependency injection, so we're not
talking about,
you know, full dependency injection frameworks.
It's a good idea to validate your event schema.
Integration tests, run them against real services,
use fakes to simulate error.
And very important to validate the handling
of integration failures, like are you surfacing
the correct exception codes, messages, so
your client knows what to do with it.
And that actually wraps up our test section. We
have the last,
last part of, oh, the tests have.
OK, the tests have run, not surprisingly,
it's almost 17 seconds
because the wait time I specified for EventBridge
was 5 seconds.
So that kind of adds to it. So what
we recommend is unit tests should definitely
run on every commit,
but some of the long-running integration tests, good
idea, and only when you explicitly
change the logic or for major releases,
so you can optimize your build time.
All right,
so we're moving to the last part of our session. Let
me just flip to
another window,
make this a little bit bigger.
OK, um.
I'm sorry, uh, I missed the phone
here. There we go.
So We, you may have
noticed that we kind of
followed certain flow,
uh,
throughout the session. So first we had our application in
a certain state,
then we figure out what needs to be changed and modified.
Then we perform the migration using the AI
and, uh, afterwards we kind of drilled
deeper into things and kind of figure out how to modify
it even further.
So this kind of flows into
the traditional way of thinking of development
life cycle but powered by
AI and this can be elevated. We
were touching lightly, to be honest, on
AI in this case,
uh, most of this stuff you can use Kira or
or any other uh coding assistant essentially to help you out
analyze the code,
uh, but what I want to emphasize here
is that we followed
essentially the, the.
The thinking, uh,
approach that corresponds with the framework
that AWS just released a few months back, which
is AIDLC or, or the AI
AI driven development life cycle
which kind of brings
structure to the chaos. So if you've followed
the news for most of the year,
a lot of people talked about white coding.
Uh, I built this in 5 minutes. I build
that in 5 minutes, which is great. But once
you get to a higher level of
complexity in your application, especially in existing
applications. You can't just white coat
your way through stuff.
uh, this is where we kind of need structure and where
spectrum and development fits into the picture very,
very nicely,
but, uh, to kind of
bring that to the whole team
on a, on a larger spectrum,
this framework is particularly useful and it's, it's
very simple. To implement actually
it has 3 stages. So
as we
did ourselves, we kinda went through the inception
phase where we kind of thought about what we
can improve.
We had AI perform a review to give us
a list that we can follow, analyze, tweak,
modify, uh, or process
otherwise.
Then we went to the construction where we actually
performed the refactoring, uh, performed
additional changes, and then deployed.
And afterwards,
Now we're gonna cover a bit of
operation. So operation essentially is the part
where you
push the production or at least
some kind of uh traffic loaded environment
where you can monitor
and evaluate your application across the span of
time. So think about a case where we would,
um, essentially evaluate our
application, uh, for let's say 3 to 6
months. It's already running,
and we want to kind of collect,
uh, the, the, the bugs or the,
the issues essentially that we have,
um. So
what I'll do right now,
essentially
just run this prompt in
here. I'll tell you in a minute what it does.
4. So,
um,
we do have a list of bugs,
uh, let me just minimize this so it's visible,
uh, that we collected over time.
You can see it's in Jason format, um,
it's hard to read, it's hard to go through it,
you know, let's make it easier on ourselves,
so. What I'll
do, I'll run this again actually,
I'll just get a summary.
And let me fan this out a bit.
So this is the summary of the Jason file that we
have. So it essentially gave us
a total sum of the bugs. Uh, we
can see there's 1 critical 17 high severity
ones, etc.
We can see individual components. So
this is essentially from the decoupled perspective,
uh, that we already, uh, talked about. We
can see which file has,
uh, which, which problems,
uh, and we can go deeper. We can, we can see which
one relates to validation, uh, serialization,
etc.
Um, now, we asked Giro if
I scroll a bit higher, to actually analyze
our
application and create a, a risk heat map,
essentially for us to understand
which parts of the application need to be modified
and how.
Alright, we gave it some extra input
just to follow the hexagonal architecture,
essentially, and it's already working on it.
Uh, it's creating a heat map, uh, now
just for the sake of time because we have 3 minutes left,
I will use
the pre-created one, so let me just flip
to that one.
Uh, here.
It actually is modifying this precreator one, so
you can see it's flickering,
uh, it just modified it,
and let me just scroll all the way
up. So,
you can see it's been just, just updated,
Kira just finished updating it, uh, if
the the file wasn't existing, it'll create a new one, of
course. But this
is similar to that uh
evaluation that audit file that we created
before essentially we got a full report
about what's happening based on uh
based on our collective bugs or bug report.
It can be locks. It can be anything. It doesn't have to
be just in the simple form as, as we, as
we saw, but we can see the highest
pin points essentially. So this is quite graphical,
uh, and Quiro can do this in even
in a higher level depending on the configuration.
There's steering that we can use to kind of
fiddle with this and make it more granular, more,
uh, customized,
uh, and this kind of brings us back to the.
Uh, previous approach where
we right now imagine we are in
operation, right? So you would imagine that's the end of it
we'll just collect it and.
That's it, right? Now, we're gonna do something
with it. So we could
do the same thing that we did in
the inception phase where we took our
audit, created a spec, and
refractor application. So, in this case, we can take our
heat map again.
Have Cro analyze it even further if we want to
create our spec
and feed it back to the inception, so we're
essentially making a full circle from the
operations to inception,
then apply through construction, essentially apply our findings,
improve our architecture, improve our application,
eliminate or minimize or mitigate
those bugs that we're running into,
and, uh,
that essentially creates the full circle
of the uh AI driven development.
PPD. In
take Yep,
so just summarizing the things we covered
today, uh, we looked at how you can basically
use Gen AI throughout the development life
cycle. So
instead of approaching it just as writing tests
for Servalli, but how do you redesign to simplify
testing,
and then we saw, so just so you know, all of
the, including property-based tests and the
application itself, we built it using hero, a
lot of the spectrum and development.
And then of course, towards the end, Thomas showed how you
can continuously iterate, uh, based
on historic data to improve your
application. Uh,
so some quick resources.
The first one is a talk from 2023,
but it's a really good breakout that talks specifically
from a Python perspective, some of the best practices.
Uh, the second one is from this year, but this
is a recorded one.
we now have really good integrations to,
uh, debug functions live, uh, using
VS code.
And the last one is the completed version of
our task API that follows all of the best
practices that's published out to GitHub, and
you should be able to access it there.
Then really quick if you're looking for service and
advent resources this is the place to go
and
that was really it. We thank you for spending
time with us for spending your last
day agreement with us.